now on the hot seat after
the 2021 draft give me one here we go
well today's draft okay i mean
let's just i'll start with an obvious
one here like not the most obvious one
but i mean hey hello andy dalton you're
on the hot seat it's officially began
yeah the team traded a first round pick
to move up nine spots to get a
quarterback from a national power who
you know everybody was going crazy about
before the draft anyways the fact that
he was gonna fall out of the top five i
mean we almost had riots in the street
over that so yeah that would be the one
where i'd say andy dalton you're on
notice for sure here and it's just a
matter of time
yeah that's not very imaginative i know
that's like taking jimmy garoppolo i i
didn't
i went one down further i i know i i
just uh you're right it was a little
obvious but it wasn't the most obvious
one
uh i'll go leighton van der rush the
cowboys line back they have micah
parsons they didn't pick up his option
what a shock
that's why a lot of these teams hold
their decision until after the draft
because if you get the replacement you
don't have to pick up the option of the
guy that you had and there was an
indication there was a thought that
maybe they were leaning in the direction
of picking up the option but now they
have michael parsons
that's part of the cruel harsh reality
of football you find the replacement the
guy that currently has that position you
no longer need yeah that's that's why i
should have took that first see i i out
thought myself there like i just i i
tried to do one that was obvious and
that was stupid but you're right that
was a good one and he's definitely
he's definitely you know on notice there
there's no doubt about it i mean that
this player is serious he's the real
deal micah parsons you heard there was
we heard enough like what was two or
three teams at least this weekend where
they like you heard michael parsons was
one of the two or three best defensive
players on their board so that's a
really real thing and then van der esh
with the neck issues too that's got to
scare the dallas cowboys um all right i
think the the guy i'll i'll say is uh
sterling shepherd there's a veteran
that's now on the hot seat you know not
that he's maybe
you know not that he's gonna like get
cut or something like that but he is
definitely in danger of losing a role
within the football team yeah i mean
darius slayton is pretty damn good kenny
galladay's making 19 million a year 18
million a year he's starting you know
you already got evan ingram a tight end
now you got cadarius tony who's a slot
type weapon guy sterling shepherd's in
the slot so cadarius tony i think would
is going to do big time infringe on the
touches of sterling shepherd and he
could find his way off the field a lot
here in 2021
yeah i'm tempted to sandbag this one one
more round but i i i
i gotta do it i gotta go kirk cousins
he's on the hot seat he is he is he
plays poorly this year you think those
vikings fans aren't going to want to see
what kel and mon can do they're going to
have a challenge in that organization to
to not let excitement build internally
and have it spill over externally
because if cousins struggles in the past
we're going to do putting sean mannion
no
now you got an alternative now you got a
guy who can become the most popular guy
in town if cousin struggles or if the
team is not living up to its potential
if it's kind of hovering around 500 in
november
uh so
hey maybe this causes kirk cousins to
react the way that aaron rodgers did
last year and if so good for the vikings
but uh for now
it puts him in a position where he's
under pressure yeah no i mean yes i mean
that to a degree you're right
i mean again yeah it could be one of
those things where if he slips and falls
here that yeah 2022 it starts a whole
conversation there's no doubt we talked
about cousins is one of those guys that
everybody's always waiting to slip and
fall or show you know some issues there
so i don't know i don't know why that is
you know people are very eager to jump
on him don't you feel that way sometimes
or am i that just well
because he's just good enough yeah he's
not i mean because
because the play has to go perfectly
because everything has to fall just
right and when that happens he can
deliver a beautiful football and move
the team down the field but he he's not
able to to take a bad day and turn it
into a good day and patrick mahomes and
other great quarterbacks can that's the
difference i think yeah no i think
you're right no doubt about it all right
i think my last one here i'm gonna like
be a little different here and just go
like bill's defensive ends they they
were they're veterans on the hot seat
the the buffalo bills let you know
that they're not happy with their d line
with their first two picks of the draft
this year and to go defense end and
rousseau and then the second round
another defense and slash defensive
tackle and carlos boogie basham who's
got a lot of high-end potential i mean
really does it's like the good mike is
is like first round good top 20 good
it's just the bad and sometimes could be
fourth round good and i think that's why
he fell into the second round but i mean
you know if you're jerry hughes mario
addison those type of guys hey even ed
oliver and the inside all of them
they've been put on notice that they got
to play better there's no doubt and that
that's what jumped out to me
i was tempted to go james robinson but
he's not really a veteran he's just got
one year but clearly travis atien is
going to supplant the undrafted guy from
last season i'll go over he mostert now
that the 49ers have trey sermon i mean
you look at their running back depth
chart right now they've kind of quietly
weeded guys out yeah and mostert is the
guy i think sermons got a chance to
uh become the guy if he plays like he
did at ohio state and he was taken for a
reason by the 49ers and you know how it
goes in that offense right in that
running game and he gets hot and
mostard's going to be on the sidelines
and that's just kind of the way it is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports